[Music]
finally finally a good barbecue the real
gear I'm joy
the gang is all here we got a we got a
little kitty I can token black girl now
I understand why the tokens name is
token and in South [ __ ] yeah we got a
Mexican girl and we got a Porsche it's
so nice to see such a diverse crowd in a
video game finally someone the distant
discriminate I relate your horses you
know I wish I was a horse and I'm really
glad that finally I feel properly
represented in a video game I also am
half palm tree so that makes me double
happy right now
are we ready to play this game I think
no I think you will never be ready to
play this game so here we go expect
nothing better than crack cocaine what
what is happening why is his hair cut
min I came up thought it was a cutscene
oh my god why he looks so beautiful I
feel like they're playing like three
different sounds tracks at the same
[ __ ] time and it's so annoying
where is she Barbie go guys let Barbra
got a kid okay how's the boyfriend in
the world great now that you're here
Barbie wrong he trying so hard not to
look at her cleavage look at him oh no
I'm just looking into her eyes they are
so beautiful
don't look at everything don't look at
actually don't look at a clip don't look
at it what's the mannequin yeah like me
did you need to thank the Jimmy where
the [ __ ] are you then how long are you
going to choose ah it's hard to play the
goddamn guitar it's scary
Brian hey Barbie how are you how are you
hey Ryan you up for game day sure if
you're there it's sure to be a Bligh
game day what
they're talking about sexual intercourse
disgusting yeah I'm scared I'm scared of
playing this game now all right okay we
can change that face like that I like
that but I don't have a problem with the
absence
yeah that's pretty fun this is
definitely so much customization I can't
decide an enrollment yeah all right then
why we did that complete [ __ ] wait to
sign let's go out there let's go
upstairs everyone hey yeah
hello how are you how'd your day I'm
having a great one Barbie Thanks
why do they feel so dead and why is it
making me feel so dead we are about to
start game see you in London Barbie the
lips doesn't move it's 2017 oh wow the
wide selection of mini games that I
can't play I'm really why why sit there
then where you going Barbie Barbie odd
you see you probably get the [ __ ] back
here [ __ ] corridor that doesn't go
anywhere okay the credit the credits
everyone
[Music]
can I [ __ ] [ __ ] stop tuning its
goddamn guitar it's so annoying
what are you doing the game option why
would you go upstairs for the option I'm
a 26 year old man and I don't understand
how you play this goddamn game okay you
up shut up shut up shut up little girl
alright the house charades is boring I
can see what is happening my new video
game oh my god yes what was that what
[Music]
secret forbidden me oh my god I haven't
felt this alive since 1980 oh where
should we go over where should we go
the Wardrobe of course good choice step
one find hidden boxes of clothes step
two put them on the right pedestals if
you're trying to sound like a robot or a
the extremely bored like I can't tell
oh my god yes hello Phoebe yeah sorry
what was I just once again put that [ __ ]
that ladder just went right through
right through her amazing amazing let me
check here I just have to click on
everything
hey I found a present could it be a
piece that perhaps sorry all right we
need to find one more thing I guess
just in case I wanted to change my
outfit I can do that while I'm playing
this game nice nice touch
I think this minigame I'll go with the
purple dress thank you
how much people could find the other
thing like I'm extremely bored and I
don't want to do this
I found it hurt you [ __ ] [ __ ]
she stole mine what's happening that was
it I just gave it a I just gave it away
what was the [ __ ] hole match the
shoes okay so what goes to would think
shoots okay thinks fast Felix do you got
this hello
okay oh we gotta go start then up [ __ ]
[ __ ] why my that was awesome
don't patronize me I don't need it [ __ ]
you okay well this this this game is
boring me to death
I'm sorry I can't I can't play with
Harvard man geez here Barbie she calling
her [ __ ] wait she has the same [ __ ]
voices her yeah command is here you two
Barbie she's talking to herself yeah
hmm you adore games don't you sure do
playing games is totally groovy I love
video games I play Call of Duty every
day I got a care package the other day
they had your mom and ass inside oh no I
can't do it the music is too good oh my
god not the cutscene I can't little
black dress across Justin all right take
you to recess in the house
I think the animation is done on par
with the cell level EDI I got it I gotta
say pretty good
Pixar you need to do better scouting
because there's so much untapped talent
out here especially the thicker it not
be how I really that was great I mean I
don't I don't approve of it whatsoever I
find it disgusting and discriminating
and very insensitive in times like these
that are everyone has having a really
rough time right now I am serving up a
challenge girls search for the cake
batter and put them on the pedestals in
the right order
who the [ __ ] is that guy who is who and
why is that guy a thing can they just
have made a barber game without all this
[ __ ] if anything I would just want to
full feature Barbie movie because the
animation is so good this is the same
game you I'm playing the same goddamn
game and it was extremely boring by the
way look I found her great you're
welcome oh look you find mine how about
that great I'll take it no I just [ __ ]
grab it [ __ ] [ __ ] that was not a
salad how did this salad become this
what is what it HAP Asian lady is giving
up
hey I got no maybe I can block her lock
it from achieving her goal that's right
you ain't going nowhere [ __ ]
where you going huh where you go huh
where you going [ __ ]
ah you block [ __ ] where you going huh
where you going I bother you will [ __ ]
with me [ __ ] she find her
pudding please find out pudding
I better blockhead you know I'm not a
microphone that's right away I'm not in
for one incredible minute I am NOT a
Barbie fan okay let that be clear I am
playing this game ironically okay I
don't actually like Barbie at all not
even a little bit not in him in a little
bit I don't even like challenge one
taking lotion what is happening why are
we throwing custard stop a mix we go
getta he got the gig up Oh rip that up
Raquel you need to stop talking
look how did I do that Markus Kane tell
ya it's like a bottle flip selling
acceptable Morris cupcakes it's called--
everybody the right side clearly has an
advantage I don't appreciate it
game is amazing I want to die with this
game in my hand between my butt cheeks
what the [ __ ] they're all bad cupcakes
they're all bad cupcakes don't touch
them Barbie don't [ __ ] talk
wait wait wait they're good cupcake I
don't understand are they bad cupcakes
or are they good cut I got 16 I didn't
even get hat I didn't even get half of
the third one this is a kids game no no
this can't be happening
I lost to those [ __ ] [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] escaped to me I kill I kill them
you have to do this [ __ ] can I not
skip this part to the love of God can I
skip this part
step one [ __ ] step one [ __ ] it's the
same game it's the same game it's the
same house fan today's event takes place
in Barbie's bedroom and looks to be a
real doozy called it the shoebox sky
scream uh-uh
[ __ ] it's a doozy that's my box hell
Cory well that's [ __ ] how am I supposed
to get the box then it's not that bad
bargain whoa hell yeah Barbie
you got him girl [ __ ] oh I got you have
too much baby hell yeah all right now
it's easy
good game good game good game good game
she's [ __ ] me good game good game
kill me don't say that word please don't
ever say that word with a capital A
would cap at all I usually got all old
caps awesome but hey I won I was in it
to win it
[ __ ] I lost you her hobbies like yeah
yeah looks like I lost that one Rick
Bennett deep violence
I must [ __ ] that [ __ ] up later imma
[ __ ] that girl's boss man alright well
that was Barbie's Dreamhouse
definitely worth it leave a like if you
enjoyed watching it maybe I'll do in
part two if enough people like it so
show your support and as always I can't
be better
brofist